[Música]
Bienvenidos a reporteros el magacín de
los grandes reportajes de la redacción
de France 24 Zoe herminia Fernández
durante años ronda ha recibido miles de
refugiados de todo el mundo actualmente
acoge a casi 130.000 principalmente de
la República democrática del Congo y
burundi y se presenta como una isla de
paz en una región asolada por diversos
conflictos que obligan a oír a millones
de personas bajo el liderazgo del
presidente polca gamé desde el 2000 la
política de refugiados del país se
considera un modelo de hospitalidad en
África y escala internacional Incluso en
2022 el país ofreció asilo a mujeres
afganas que huían de la llegada de los
talibanes al poder a esto se añade el
hecho desde que el 2019 kigali cuenta
con un programa de acogida de refugiados
procedente de Libia creado por acnur
también desde el pasado mes de abril
Ruanda firmó un acuerdo con el Reino
Unido para reubicar a personas
solicitantes de asilo que lleguen desde
el país británico sin examinar su
solicitudes Ruanda y el reto de los
refugiados un reportaje de nuestra
corresponsal Marian conné a quien
tenemos hoy en el programa le saludo
Marian y le pregunto en el reportaje
mencionas el tema de los refugiados en
el este de la República del Congo que
cruzan cada día la frontera con Ruanda
Existe alguna perspectiva de poner fin a
esta crisis
Sí esta crisis tiene sus orígenes en los
años 90 con la primera y segunda guerra
del Congo que desembocaron en otro
conflicto la guerra de iq y es esta
última que parece eternizarse la
situación se deterioró especialmente a
finales de 2021 con el regreso de un
grupo armado el 23 apoyando por Ruanda
según la ONU según las estimaciones
también 120 grupos armados actúan
actualmente en el este de la República
democrática del Congo las regiones de la
inestabilidad de la región son étnicas
políticas y sobre todo económicas con la
explotación de minerales como el cobalto
que ahora se utiliza en la fabricación
de teléfonos por ejemplo tras casi 30
años y en estabilidad esta crisis han
dejado más de 4 millones de muertos y
otros tantos desplazados y a pesar de
este terríco balance y de la implicación
de la comunidad internacional la
situación en el este de la República
democrática del Congo parece lejos de
haber terminado y las primeras víctimas
son los niños como se puede ver en el
reportaje sí Marian ya volvemos con
usted veamos el reportaje
[Música]
rubabo el distrito fronterizo entre
Ruanda y el Congo
también es aquí donde desde hace más de
20 años miles de refugiados congoleños
se dirigen a Ruanda huyendo de la
inestabilidad en el este de su país
por su seguridad debemos preservar sus
identidades
cuando crucé la frontera vi una imagen
muy buena porque aquí no hay tribalismo
puedo caminar en paz Aquí hay una
diferencia con mi país la República
democrática del Congo
olvidados por una comunidad
internacional y cansados de la
inestabilidad que viven desde hace
décadas todavía decenas de refugiados
cruzan las fronteras entre Ruanda y el
Congo cada día la mayoría son mujeres
con sus bebés
y algunos preadolescentes muy jóvenes
como Remy
con solo nueve años sus padres
prefirieron dejarlo viajar solo a Ruanda
desde la región de masisi por falta de
dinero
hoy tras varios días de viaje él y otras
10 personas de la misma región han
llegado al campo de tránsito de Camila a
unos 20 kilómetros de distancia de la
frontera
los recién llegados deben pasar por esta
tienda para registrarse como residentes
del refugio y sobre todo para someterse
a un chequeo médico me llamo Denis y voy
a hacerte unas preguntas
cuántos años tienes
para todos los que llegan aquí es
obligatorio un chequeo médico para que
podamos determinar sus necesidades lo
antes posible para prevenir al máximo
las epidemias en el campamento
[Música]
así que por el bien de todos llevamos a
cabo estos exámenes cuando llegan aquí
los exámenes son complicados para Remmy
que tiene dificultades para responder a
las preguntas pero este ojo parece tener
un problema cuánto tiempo lleva así
mucho tiempo creo que tiene que venir
con su madre porque hay muchas cosas que
no puede responder lo entiendes
tienes que volver con mamá
una escena que despierta la ternura de
Jim que se ha cruzado con estos cuatro
niños que han llegado en el mismo
autobús que Remi
Cuando veo esta situación crees que
podría haberme ido y de haber dejado a
mis hijos sería capaz de hacerlo Te
imaginas que los mataran como los demás
refugiados congoleños de este campamento
gin huyó de la región de que hubo un
Norte donde 120 grupos armados luchan
entre sí y llevan a cabo un reino del
terror desde finales de los años 90 todo
por controlar territorios para extraer
minerales preciosos pero también por
motivos étnicos tras más de una semana
de incertidumbre ella y su familia
tendrán derecho a algunas necesidades
básicas como este espacio que le servirá
de hogar
ahora estoy contenta porque donde
estábamos había milicianos de miniatura
que nos asustaban una mañana cuando nos
despertamos encontramos los cadáveres de
nuestras vacas decidimos huir porque
teníamos miedo de ser atacados No he
dormido en una semana a causa de este
miedo pero ahora que estoy aquí me han
dado todo lo que necesito Estoy muy
contenta mientras Jim sigue instalándose
Al otro lado del campamento Remi
permanece en la tienda con los médicos
por primera vez en días tiene la
perspectiva de dormir en otro sitio que
no sea el suelo
estoy muy contento por qué porque han
aceptado acogernos te dijeron tus padres
A dónde ibas Y qué ibas a hacer
me dijeron que iba a ir al campo de
namira a vivir
mucho antes que Remi cientos de personas
llegaron al campo de camira sin padres
hoy asisten a clases en el campamento
con la esperanza de poder entrar algún
día en el sistema escolar ordinario
ruandés
tengo 120 alumnos por clase Así que es
complicado dar clase son disipados y les
gusta charlar a veces les oigo hablar de
su vida anterior al campo es una
historia violenta porque vienen de zonas
de guerra donde mataron a la gente la
mayoría huyó sin traer nada consigo Así
que inevitablemente tienen secuelas es
muy complicado Porque algunos tienden
aislarse por lo que han visto Pierre que
llegó en enero tiene muchas secuelas lo
extraño el Congo porque la gente nos
perseguía también venían a atacarnos por
la noche y nos decían que éramos tutsis
pronto Pierre podrán incorporarse a uno
de los cinco campos de refugiados
repartidos por Ruanda o vivir en la
ciudad como Abraham y él solo 9% de los
refugiados en Ruanda
llegó a Ruanda hace cinco años huyendo
de su país de origen Sudán del sur
después de que parte de su familia fuera
masacrada
tras vivir varios años en uganda
finalmente se instaló en Ruanda y hoy
tras dos años de lucha ha consignado
dejar el campo de mahama
además de los cursos que siguen la
universidad El joven realiza un trabajo
tras otro y aquí es profesor en una
prestigiosa escuela de kigali aquí les
enseño cómo usar Excel pero también
otros programas informáticos
La idea es que tengan un buen nivel para
estar preparados para los exámenes
a sus 25 años y a pesar de su imponente
estatura de casi dos metros Abraham vive
con un miedo constante al futuro
no me veo viviendo en Ruanda
incluso los ruandeses tienen problemas
para llegar a fin de mes
Así que ni hablamos
mientras Abraham le cuesta imaginarse un
futuro en Ruanda el gobierno ruandés
firmó hace más de un año un acuerdo sin
precedentes con el Reino Unido
es una Primicia mundial
es un acuerdo sobre migración y economía
entre Ruanda y el Reino Unido
en virtud del acuerdo todos los que
llegan ilegalmente al Reino Unido como
los que cruzan ilegalmente el Canal de
la Mancha en pequeñas y peligrosas
embarcaciones serán reubicados en Ruanda
un proyecto por el que el gobierno
ruandés recibirá 140 millones de libras
más de 176 millones de dólares
sin embargo desde la firma del acuerdo
el proyecto ha sido muy criticado en
particular por las numerosas violaciones
de los Derechos Humanos de las que
varias ong acusan regularmente a Ruanda
en primer lugar lo primero que la gente
tiene que entender y saber
es que el hecho de que nos enteremos de
informes de ong y organizaciones ya no
asusta a nadie
que quede claro
eso ya no impedirá que los países
africanos y Ruanda en particular sigan
avanzando
pero a pesar de la indignación provocada
por la reacciones a este acuerdo a nivel
del gobierno ruandés las más altas
autoridades Empezando por el alto
comisionado para los refugiados refutan
este proyecto
acnur ha sido muy claro al decir que nos
oponemos a cualquier acuerdo de
externalización para los refugiados como
es el caso del acuerdo entre Reino Unido
y Ruanda y no se trata solo de estos
países cualquier país que se plantee
hacer esto nuestra postura es la misma
va en contra de la convención sobre los
refugiados en el caso del acuerdo entre
Reino Unido y Ruanda actualmente se está
llevando a cabo un procedimiento en
Reino Unido y estamos esperando a ver
los resultados
la oposición ruandesa duda de la
capacidad de Ruanda para llevar a cabo
este proyecto a largo plazo
aquí tenemos un desempleo muy alto entre
los jóvenes
Así que si traen a gente recibirán ayuda
del Reino Unido pero después de cinco
años serán responsabilidad del gobierno
ruandés
qué va a pasar puede que los ruandeses
no hablen de ello pero si lo pensamos
bien la tierra también es un gran reto
en Ruanda tenemos 26.000 metros
cuadrados para 13 millones de habitantes
somos Pues el país más densamente
poblado de África
lejos de importarle las críticas y para
hacer realidad esta Promesa de acoger a
los migrantes
Ruanda ya está construyendo los
alojamientos donde vivirán ellos se
obtienen el estatuto de refugiado y
desean permanecer en Ruanda
Esta es la fase final
han terminado de cavar y vestir ahora
pasamos a la fase final que es la
pintura
aquí refugiados irlandeses convivirán el
alojamientos que van desde los más
pequeños para parejas Hasta los más
grandes para familias
habrá un supermercado eso es lo primero
desde aquí hasta el centro de kigali hay
solo 30 km
Así que está justo al lado del centro de
la ciudad donde encontrarás la mayoría
de los restaurantes servicios y tiendas
la gente tendrá todo lo que necesita
para llevar una vida cómoda
alejado de la polémica que rodea a este
acuerdo Abraham va logrando poco a poco
sus objetivos en Ruanda
no somos refugiados como ellos nuestros
países no han firmado ningún acuerdo
solo Temo que cuando vengan nuestras
vidas serán más complicadas porque nos
prestarán menos atención
hoy se reúne con sus amigos también
refugiados pero de burundí que se
preguntan Qué impacto Podría tener esto
en sus vidas
me Temo que empeorará las cosas para
nosotros
Porque se les prestará más atención
y claro por su procedencia También
tienen que respetar lo que firmaron
un miedo al empeoramiento de las
condiciones de vida que dificulta aún
más los sueños de Abraham y los de sus
amigos en lo relativo al llegar a
occidente
si puedo elegir prefiero vivir fuera del
continente africano si tengo la suerte
por ejemplo de irme a vivir a Canadá a
Francia u otro país donde pueda recibir
una buena educación
mi deseo es tener un impacto y cambiar
las cosas
pero no se puede tener un impacto en la
vida quedándose aquí en kigali un país
donde incluso puedo cuidarme y estudiar
al mismo tiempo
Ruanda acoge actualmente acerca de
130.000 refugiados principalmente de la
República democrática del Congo y de
burundí
alcanzar occidente no es fácil para los
refugiados que viven en Ruanda
sobre todo porque desde hace algunas
décadas Europa es el continente que
menos refugiados acoge
según la ONU en 2021 el 83% de los
refugiados fueron recibidos en países de
renta baja
estamos de vuelta con mariannette y le
pregunto después de ver el reportaje se
ha afirmado un acuerdo sin precedentes
entre ronda y el Reino Unido Es la
primera vez que Ruanda firma un acuerdo
de este tipo
públicamente se trata del primer acuerdo
de este tipo firmado por Ruanda pero ya
en 2013 el país tenía un acuerdo similar
con Israel a diferencia del acuerdo con
Reino Unido este acuerdo nunca se hizo
público y pero ya que los solicitantes
de Angelo israelíes principalmente
eritreos y sudaneses fueran llevando a
Ruanda Y uganda a cambio de dinero según
una investigación de la bbc este acuerdo
fue abandonado en 2018 después de que
casi 4.000 solicitantes de ácidos
israelíes fueron
deportados aruanda y uganda pero Ruanda
siempre ha negado la existencia de tal
acuerdo con Israel a pesar de la
controversia provocada por el acuerdo de
Ruanda con el Reino Unido puesto en el
contexto global nos dándose cuenta de
que es simplemente un elemento más en el
deterioro de los derechos de los
refugiados en todo el mundo esto incluye
la normalización de la delegación de la
gestión de los refugiados de los países
ricos a los países de renta baja Gracias
mariani a ustedes por acompañarnos hasta
aquí reporteros de la semana recuerde
que para sintonizar esta y las emisiones
anteriores puede visitar nuestro sitio
web France 24.com hasta la próxima
[Música]